Charlie and the Chocolate Factory a
seemingly innocent story for children
yet contains gruesome industrial candy
accidents that one by one takes children
out of the running for that Golden
Tickets prize but the end they show that
they're all okay and everything worked
out what you know what that's the
coward's way out through new visual
effects newly shot scenes new edits new
sound design we want to present to you a
reimagined version of Charlie in the
Chocolate Factory for each one of these
scenes shows what really happened let's
take a look at how we make it we're
joined here by Ian Hubert Peter France
both VFX masters guys we wanted to look
at this with you guys and take a look at
smooth shots and brainstorm together how
can we make this really crazy what kind
of things could we do to it let's vote
the movie I watched it for the first
time last night like I've connected with
these characters you know and now we're
gonna have to put them down it's gonna
be such a cool set so this thing it
shrinks it transfers the chocolate bar
and shrinks it down I guess Mike teevee
is tiny now he got turned into
particulate and then reassembled what if
we pulled a Galaxy Quest and Mike teevee
was reassembled wrong dude
yeah dude that could totally happen to
Mike teavee she faints at the end of
that scene - lets go - Gustus gloop
this was like the most disturbing in my
opinion like the reason the scene messed
with me as a kid was because it was so
claustrophobic horrifying dude just the
red smear as he moves up the pipe I
don't know I'm from that shot where you
could just see you said you have to have
the stream just go straight through
sculpt this like inflate up against the
glass Oh Oh pressure just keeps building
and he just bursts dude this grows the
worst yeah all right wailed
Veruca Salt
[Music]
this one kind of feels like the
producers are just like yeah one more
time for gifts drop her in a box trap
door gig done so I was thinking this is
a great opportunity just to do the human
pachinko machine so she falls through
that then it cuts to a rag doll of her
knocked all over the place we'd
basically be paying off what the
audience has always been fighting to see
we also have the fan scene and that's
just waiting to be violent yeah
eventually they get up there
oh dude those fingers feel like might be
a little tricky compositing wise with
all those bubbles in the foreground oh
yeah you're right though those bubbles
are gonna be hard to deal with though
what do you guys want to get fancy on
here anything involving soft buddy
physics this is my game what he said but
the exact opposite rigid body physics
pick any scene claim it for yourself go
for it lame augustus Gloop all right key
you're stepping up to the gloop
challenge very happily do that bubble
one okay okay great
well I would love to try the rag doll
okay and then I'll grab a Thomas TV
what's his name Mike TV Mike TV
gentlemen right look at that look at
that synchronization every entertainment
the fact that Peters in the middle of a
hike yes okay so you can see here we got
our shot of mr. gloop but you know I'm
not sure that I buy this performance in
theory he has chocolate shooting up
through his butthole and so I imagine
that would be a bit more painful than
he's expressing here so as with most
things I decided to recreate this in CGI
I use this great software a free
software called make human basically it
gives you a generic person model and you
have all these sliders for gender age
muscle weight that gives you a whole
skeleton you can work with what I did
was I projected the footage of gloops
head on to the 3d model of glue since I
didn't really believe his performance I
decided to do my own so I did a little
janky home motion capture of just
recording my face with my cell phone
bring that into blender and then go
through frame by frame using these face
bones to match the performance of me to
the mall
I've taken some artistic Liberty with
the eye rolling and shaking of the head
but for the most part it matched my
performance from then on it's pretty
straightforward we just bring our render
into After Effects overlay it over the
background overlay it's in glass overlay
the pipe we're good to go
No
for the second shot we're not mixing
this with no live-action footage I took
a wide shot of the whole environment and
I painted out to the bike we got that in
blender and what I'm gonna do is use the
knife tool to cut out some little
doohickeys extrude it to give our
background some depth we get this a
super janky but usable background out of
focus totally works
I also went ahead and recreated the
pipes in blender put it around mr.
Augustus to show his body inflating with
chocolate I decided to use a displace
modifier which basically takes the
geometry of his body and just pushes it
outward he's been inflating with
chocolate eventually there's gonna be a
breaking point a simple fluid simulation
you just set the z-axis velocity to like
10 feet per second and just let it shoot
up into the atmosphere do you get a
fluid simulation like this then to top
it all off we add a material we have a
nice mixture of blood and chocolate here
and there you go Wolfe has successfully
been exploded killing Charlie Bucket and
Grandpa Joe Wow what a dream come true
so my thought was the grandpa Joe would
be excited to be flying and so he would
fly straight through the family and then
the sphincter opens and the fan comes
out and it chews up some Charlie paste
down below in a spray of exactly 100,000
drops of grandpa blood grandpa was easy
just cut out an image from the movie and
attached a few vertices to control
objects so yeah good bye but Charlie's
trickier I put a few textures from the
movie onto a human shape and he looks
kind of like a nightmare but I stuck an
image at the top of his head on the top
of his head and it looks like the top of
his head so that works but how to
animate I have a Rococo motion capture
suit so I was gonna use that but first I
have to get inside his head
what is Charlie like what is he thinking
in these final moments fear sure but
also shame at the theft of the fizzy
lifting drinks and acceptance of his
punishment for reaching above his
station with that in mind I acted out
Charlie's final desperate moments first
one leg then the other
we're done okay so while all the guys
are working on their respective the
effect shot it's my job to edit together
a piece that can kind of string these
the effects sequences together into a
story I have to make the setup for the
payoff that they're working on there's
tons of stuff to work with in the movie
if you're trying to recontextualize some
of these shots Roald Dahl was known for
going to dark places and his writing so
there's a lot of that just inherently in
this story now while Willy Wonka may be
a psychopathic murderer in this world
was setting up what if we took it a step
further and actually had Charlie commit
murder to get his grubby hands on one of
them golden tickets there's a sequence
where Charlie's walking in the street at
night those shots are very dramatic
they're very kind of dark shots he's in
a kind of dark mental space in the film
why not push it one step further and
make him contemplating murder there's a
couple building blocks to tell this
story that are missing though one
there's no target for Charlie to kill he
needs to have a victim too there's no
shot of Charlie wielding a weapon in
three there's no shot that explicitly
pays off
so some pickup shots were necessary I
went to the only place I could think of
that really felt like 1970s England
there's a place called post alley in
Seattle there's a famous gum wall there
this place was perfect dress-- my dad up
as an old drunk guy it worked out great
then I got a shot of a knife being
pulled out of the pocket a couple shots
of Charlie rummaging through the jacket
and finding a golden ticket
I think the shots turn out great and
they're gonna give us what we need to
tell this story the only thing left is
some sound design I've asked some of the
guys to record some screams of the
victims as they fall prey to Willy Wonka
all right Nick has asked me to sit down
and record some audio assets for the
Willy Wonka piece he wants me to do some
ADR maybe some vio for some of the
characters and things like that well I
thought that there'd be no better
opportunity to tell you guys about
today's sponsor expressvpn through these
recordings right here you may have heard
that expressvpn protects you from
hackers trying to steal your information
but what you might not also know is that
it can expand your entertainment
selection keep your private information
private and keep your sensitive work
secure that was perfect you can express
VPN they'll encrypt all your online data
giving you a layer of protection from
people like the government think about
all the confidential information that
you handle misconfigurations on your
device or malware infected router could
put your data at risk of being stolen by
hackers get to the throat through
expressvpn
you can have and change your location so
that shows movies that used to not be
available in your country but now
available do you think that was too long
expressvpn ensures that 100% of your
data being transferred between your
devices and the internet is encrypted if
you're interested in trying expressvpn
for yourself head on over to expressvpn
dot-com slash corridor crude you'll get
three months free when you sign up
that's when I'm done so the Mike TV
microwave shot the first place I started
was Maximo coms places great looked up
some sort of painful lying on the ground
in pain motion capture data downloaded
this into c4d so you get this guy
writhing around on the ground I select
the joints here and I just start scaling
things move things around and you start
to get some really weird Sims glitchy
effects here then I started to texture
things referenced stuff like real
loans on Google and gross images from
that show Chernobyl and basically came
up with something like this these dark
parts here you have like a real nasty
red pulpy fleshy material and then you
have this top layer which is more like
just your normal skin real nice wet
reflection on that thing like it just
looks oh it looks horrible he is not
having a good time here I lit the scene
with a couple area lights made sure I
got that real nice harsh edge light on
this guy and the last thing that we did
here was had some goo turns into a
melted piece of skin for that I used X
particles there's just an emitter set to
object mode and yeah that's Mike TV in
the microwave I can't wait to see what
the other guys have up their sleeve is
relatively straightforward you just take
your model and you break it into chunks
forearms biceps top of the torso middle
torso the head the neck and connect to
each one of those things with joints
it's like the elbow is just a basic
hinge for example so using all these
different joints I linked all the
different parts together and then I
could just hit play and the whole thing
would tumble to the ground problem was
setting up joints that match the range
of motion for a human body is actually a
lot more complicated than I thought a 3d
object has something called a pivot
basically it's like the central point of
the object that tells where it is in 3d
space and apparently pivot affects the
orientation of the joint so I discovered
that the pivot points my bones had been
altered to point sideways when it was on
the arms rather than normal up and down
side to reorient all that fixed my
joints and once that was looking good I
knew I was ready to start my full
animations I had to build a stunt route
you know for the character to hit things
like now I wanted to slide into
something and smack off on something
else along vaguely the thing is with
physics you can't animate it you just
just set it up and hope that nature
takes its course and that your character
will hit all the things it's supposed to
hit finally
and I was happy with and now I'm going
to build a whole factory around that and
actually decorate it to look like it's a
part of a whole factory system I used
kit Bosch Brutalism
architecture model pack to kind of basic
deal on my factory backgrounds and all
these archways and concrete decoration
things like I would have taken away too
long for me to make you know I have this
theme that just comes to life now
there's cool lights everywhere and now I
had my character get this and hitting
that and that was that and render it out
now the motion blur in the depth of
field at all stuff plus the realistic
lighting added a lot of time to the
renderer this actually took me an entire
week to render yeah that's how I made
the ragdoll animation awesome all right
we have some final shots to look at so
excited yeah I hadn't seen any of your
guys's shots I'm just not sure you guys
are gonna hire me after you see this so
amped let's do it
oh here we go and now details on the
sudden announcement that has captured
the attention of the entire world hidden
among the countless billions of Wonka
bars are five gold tickets and to the
five people who find them will come the
most fabulous prize one could wish for a
lifetime supply of chocolates
[Music]
nobody ever comes out Wow are the old
knife man
[Music]
like an old fault or a lifetime supply
of chocolate chocolate this is Willy
Wonka directed by Stanley Kubrick lock
in the morning of the first day of
October and do not be late
it's nice to have you here I'm so glad
you compromise this is going to be such
an exciting day I hope you enjoy it I
think you will buy the nerve center to
the entire Wonka's factory
oh the blood barrier inside this room
all of my dreams become reality pressure
is building up behind the blockage
man you got a garbage strike going on in
Wonka oh who wants an Everlasting
Gobstopper I can only give them to you
if you solemnly swear to keep turning
violet violet
[Music]
well well well - naughty nasty little
children gone
three children left these are the geese
that lay the golden eggs as you can see
they're larger than ordinary geese hey
daddy I want two golden goose here we go
again
how much do you want for the golden
goose they're not for sale name -
promise
she can't have one he was a bad egg that
would you all please put these on
there's dangerous stuff inside one
commission my very latest and greatest
invention here it comes
there it is it's here taste it it's
delicious it's just got a small parting
is there a thief in a swindler excuse me
for not showing you out straight up the
stairs you'll find the way and goodbye
to you both
I'll have to take a break charlie
nobody's watching
[Music]
oh my god everyone that was terrifying
cinema I'm glad my goodness oh my god
that all looks really good you guys
freaking killed it man the goo and the
piper whatever his name is Charlie the
door that closes and traps perfect chefs
kiss for that that end sequence sighs
like that chopper grinded up pulp just
freakin nut meat dude just even the
blood on his face
after he stabbed the guy it was so good
the blood on the face when he comes to
yeah a long time on that yeah
Nico that like when it cut to the your
first your first shot I thought it was
actually part of the thing for reals
like I don't remember this like aimless
and it was lit really well thanks for
out of that man that was really good
every minute working on this was a blast
and what a payoff to see all this come
together like it's the best feeling ever
that was amazing like that line you've
put in there eraser head like little
corpse on the screen Peter you kept your
graph going upwards for crazy acts I
feel like Sam did he do these shots for
this yeah I did all the Blood River
stuff yeah I've been all the the guts
dropping port in there yeah the meat
what a testament to like the technology
these days that we all have like fluid
simulations and like physics simulations
and hair simulations and like so much
stuff going on like all in our scenes
that like we've all just did yeah yeah
pretty nuts if you want to watch wonky
Willie uncut without a react
we have it uploaded to the corridor
channel also we made a playlist of our
favorite Ian Hubert videos and Peter
France videos
Ian makes these incredible lazy
tutorials that are the funniest thing
I've ever seen and Peter has made the
spider-man film that's not so I can't
believe one guy did it but we have a
link to that in some of those great
tutorials as well don't forget to
subscribe to core crew and here's a
little sneak peek just something that's
gonna be coming out in a few weeks
on the store alright see you guys the
next one thanks for watching I can't
find any sounds online of someone
gurgling up liquid repeatedly I need to
get creative here
[Music]